and then we finally get to this gym when
I kind of see this weird entrance and we
pull it to the gate and it's a dude in a
military outfit and I go uh hey man I'm
trying to get to the gym is it on base
he's like yeah is this an Uber I say
yeah he puts his hand on the butt of the
rifle and he starts inspecting into the
Uber I say so the gym is on base he said
yeah this is a military base I say is it
open to the public and then he goes well
she can't come in but you're good I say
no dude is the gym on base open to the
public and he said yeah you got an ID I
said what kind of ID he goes military ID
I say no dude I'm a civilian I'm asking
if the gym is open to the public then he
goes no this is a military base
and I was like I can [__] see that
then he turns to his pal in the booth
he's like this [__] guy and I just I
never felt so angry I'm like I've been
asking you if it's open to the public
yeah I thought you were talking about
public military guys yeah I'm just like
oh my [__] military guys out in the
public